with the playstation 5 upon us let's
take a look back on all
of the playstation's launch titles not
just because nostalgia is one hell of a
drug
but to see how they stack up against the
latest console
[Music]
hmm you hear that that's the sound of
unadulterated
sonic beauty the boot up sound to the
box of magic that started
it all the playstation released here in
the states on september 9th
1995 it brought with it 12 games
air combat battle arena toshinden a
games marketing campaign focused solely
on getting beat up by a girl
like to be humiliated by women
here's your dream date espn extreme
games downhill raced on a skateboard and
punch dudes
it was a stream anyways kiliak the dna
imperative nba jam tournament edition
hey you want some peanut butter with
that jam
power serve 3d tennis the raiden project
rayman man what a dude the goat the game
was hard as [ __ ] though
ridge racer rage racer
street fighter the movie the best street
fighter game
of all time total eclipse turbo and
lastly
zero divide
on october 26 2000 we dived into the
black abyss of potential with the
playstation 2.
it could play dvds and it launched with
a lot of games so here we go armored
core 2
dead or alive 2 hardcore dynasty
warriors 2
espn international track and field did
not
know that existed espn winter x games
snowboarding
didn't know that didn't know about that
one either
eternal ring a from software game about
a ring
coming out i doubt you could
even imagine it evergrace
fanta vision not to be confused with the
soda guff
gun grif gun gifford gun griffin blaze
oh i don't know about any of these
apparently kessin madden nfl 2001
midnight club street racing ah before
rockstar made motion picture moving
games i'll have
two number nines a number nine
large a number six with extra dip
a number seven two number 45s
one with cheese and a large soap
nhl 2001 orphan cyan of sorcery
cue ball billiards master
must have been a system seller ready to
rumble boxing round two
rage racer five rage racer
silence scope smugglers run not the
disneyland ride but
also a rockstar game street fighter ex3
no it's
not the street fighter movie game but
whatever summoner
surfing h3o
not h2o and it's another rock star
distributed gem wow swing away golf
tekken tag tournament time splitters
damn that game was so good
unreal tournament wild wild racing
[Music]
x-squad man remember when you learned
the towers on the boot-up screen
represented the memory card data
wild
ah pure elegance ps3 the comeback kid of
the bunch
released on november 17 2006 and
well i couldn't afford it but hey that's
all right instead i just looked at these
launch titles from a
sad and penniless distance titles like
blazing angels squadrons of world war ii
call of duty 3 the infamous giant enemy
crab game or also known as the
genji days of the blade madden nfl 07
marvel ultimate alliance mobile suit
gundam crossfire
nba 2k7 nhl 2k7
resistance fall of man an insomniac
classic before
spider-man top-tier puddles in that one
rage racer
seven there's always a ridge racer tiger
woods pga 207
tony hawk's project eight untold legends
dark kingdom
on november 15 2013 this sleek
futuristic doorstop looking dude came
into our lives
and swept the generation right off its
feet leading into it with
angry birds star wars
assassin's creed iv black flag
battlefield 4
call of duty ghosts fifa 14 injustice
gods among us
ultimate edition just dance 2014
killzone shadowfall lego marvel
superheroes
madden nfl 25 nba 2k14
need for speed rivals skylanders swat
force
warframe sadly no ridge racer for the
ps4
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never
so long the days of a screaming ps4 fan
and hello the ps5
as for launch titles so far the
playstation 5 is charging into the new
generation with some heavy hitters from
the looks of it as of this recording we
have
assassin's creed valhalla astros
playroom
bug snacks call of duty black ops cold
war
demon souls destruction all-stars not to
be confused with playstation all-stars
rip devil may cry 5 special edition
fortnite because you can't get that
anywhere else
except for a launch title on the ps5
that's mean
godfall just dance 2021 man-eater
marvel's spider-man miles morales marvel
spider-man remastered mortal kombat 11
ultimate
nba 2k 21 observer system redux sac boy
a big adventure
the pathless and watch dogs legion oh
playstation 4
time to shove you in a box that i keep
in my closet to reminisce about like a
distant memory or that birthday card my
mom sent me because i felt too guilty to
throw it away
you've been a wonderful friend for more
on playstation past present and future
keep your eyes on gamespot and while
you're at it
check out generation next it's the show
about next
generation consoles yeah anyways
thanks for watching
[Music]
you